La Volta al Montapeu, day 252, a very placid night, there were the cows, which were anchored, so they couldn't come, a bit of noise from some machines, and in the background here the mountains of Tajikistan, these mountains of 2,000 meters, I think, are Tajikistan.
Well, it's 6.37, I think, for what I've read on the internet, the border with Tajikistan, which is the first border I've ever seen, that I believe in my life, well, it looks like it won't open until 8 o'clock, so I have an hour and a half to see if I can find a restaurant to have lunch and spend my last soms uzbeks.
I'm already gathered, it's 6 o'clock, is a person coming? Well, he was coming, yes.
I don't know if he's the cowkeeper, I don't know who he is, I don't know if he's seen me, well, I'll be back now and I'll pass, I'll call him, let's see what he says, I'll leave my cell phone on, let's see.
Salam.
Turuta.
Well, nothing, salam aleikum, salam aleikum, and that's it.
No idea, you.
The border.
Well, there, in the back where those trucks are, that's already the border, the market map, that maybe there's a place to eat something, I don't know.
I don't know.
Well, before reaching the border, Uzbekistan summary, 40 km I have done in total, 200 and a bit of positive signal, the best in Uzbekistan, well, we will not do a top 3,
no competition for anything, man prices, it is the most expensive country I have ever been, the people are quite nice, and food is quite good.
What I've spent, in... without counting the plane, without counting the post them, and without counting the visa to Tajikistan, to travel, which I spent one week?
Uzbekistan?
Hotels...
Three trains that I took, dinars...
beer and such, 380 euros.
Man, it's very cheap, huh? Very cheap.
I haven't been much of anything.
I haven't taken the most expensive hotels, but I haven't taken the cheapest either, because I haven't been to a hostel.
Very good, you. I mean, it's very good here.
Let's see if I can eat something. I see that there is not much queue, huh?
I see that there are not many cars.
Well, but I see that they pass, I mean, that maybe it is already open to the border.
Nothing, you, it's all closed. The only open, in quotes, is a woman here who serves coffee
and a kind of tortitas that I have added a little tomato on top.
I haven't managed to spend the money I had.
I don't mind changing money, but I have very little, I don't even have 5 euros.
Well, these people back here are waiting to enter.
I guess at 8 o'clock.
I don't know, maybe I should have put the queue, but well, I won't put it.
It's still 7.20.
I'm going to have breakfast and that's it.
I could make a queue, but there is no queue.
The queue is very small, the typical queue that people are putting on the sides and such.
Anyway, I've arrived too early.
I should have slept a little more, which also suits me.
Nothing, if nothing happens, we'll see each other on the other side of the border.
In principle, the visa has its own system, so I'll just have to show the passport
and I hope that the visa, the stamp, is reflected that it is 60 days and not 30.
In principle, there shouldn't be any more problem.
Well, the update seems to be fast.
I'm going to enter now, but I managed to change the 2 euros and a half that I had,
Osweca currency, and they gave me 40 of the Tajik currency.
I'm sure they cheated on me.
They must have cheated on me.
But well, at least I have 20 that for a coffee or something will be useful.
Let's go.
I've made it.
I'm in Tajikistan.
Let's see, border closure report.
Well, first I go to the first filter, which is the Uzbekistan exit.
First, a man looks at my passport, very nice, and says to me, okay, come in.
And when I've already passed, he says to me, wait, wait, come back.
He takes my phone, that is, he tells me to take off my phone and says, please open the camera in the gallery.
And he has made me delete all the videos that I have recorded at the border, that you can see the border.
But of course, what this man has not taken into account is that I, in theory, all the videos that are in the folder that I have deleted,
I can recover them.
Well, I haven't done it yet.
But yes, maybe I can recover them.
So, it's a bit embarrassing now that I think about it.
Putting these videos on the internet because they are seen.
Well, let's see.
Well, it doesn't matter.
I think nothing will happen.
Okay, what else?
Then there has been the exit of Uzbekistan, which they have suggested to me.
I had to make a bit of a queue.
They have suggested the exit, no problem, obviously.
The exit, everything is fine.
The entrance to Tajikistan, well, here they are not in the same building, they are two separate buildings.
With a lot of security, in fact.
And well, you leave Uzbekistan, you go through a few doors, you enter Tajikistan.
And well, here is where I was more nervous for the entrance, right?
But no, no, no.
It has been super easy, super fast.
I have given the passport.
The guy has not asked any questions.
He has put it in a machine and he has suggested it to me.
Then there is when I have asked, 60 days?
Because of course, my visa, for what I have paid, is 60.
In 30 days I already know that I can enter without a visa.
Then I have asked the guy, he has asked another.
He says, is this the tourist visa you asked for?
I say yes.
He says, well, 60.
Well, it has not just inspired me so much trust.
But well, we'll assume that if they have told me, it's okay, right?
It's okay, right?
In any case, I'm inside and nothing.
Here at the exit, a lot of taxis, saying, hey, hey, you want to go to Dushanbe?
Do you want to go to Dushanbe?
I no no.
I go walking.
Okay, next stop the next town that I do not remember what they call it.
It starts with P.
It's 20 kilometers and there I can buy the SIM and take cash from the cashier.
There is some clouds.
which is something that is perfect, and go alone, which we had not seen in Uzbekistan. Let's go!
From the boring landscape of Uzbekistan, all of a sudden we have passed this, eh?
These mountains, with the river next to it, a lot of trees here, and we have just started, eh?
In fact, it will be one of the few plans that we will see in the whole country.
What is left when we enter the mountains, plans, well, Dushanbe is flat, but the rest, I would say, that's it.
Hello! Well, I can't say anything, I can't take an hour walking.
And the map, and here on the road, it says that there is a place from UNESCO, here on the side, about 600 meters,
I don't know,
it looks like a format, it looks like an archaeological site, with remains of some population that lived here 4,000 years ago.
Well, we're not far, let's go see it.
Well, what a door, eh? They have put their heart into it, eh?
Because this is UNESCO's monument, it's not very old, I think it's about 10 years old or so, and they made me pay.
3 dollars, 3 dollars, no, 4 dollars.
I paid with a 5-dollar bill, of course, I didn't have, I only had 20 cash bills, well, the change was not very good, but well, it's fine.
Well, let's see, how about it? Look, all this, which has a kind of roof on top, means that they are, well, remains of these archaeological sites.
Let's see. Wow, this is 3,000-4,000 years old, that's a lot, huh? I don't know if I've ever been to a place like this.
I think it's quite well preserved.
Well, obviously, here, some kind of arrangement has been made, right?
It is said that this is an ancient temple, and that it was discovered in the eleventh century.
In the year 1000, they were already doing excavations, huh?
This, perhaps, is the most interesting excavation, not because it is the most beautiful, but because here they found three tombs.
One of them belonged to the princess of Sarazam. Sarazam is this place.
Well, of course, 3,000 years ago they didn't know if it was a princess or not, but it was the body of a 19-20-year-old woman who was covered with lapis lazuli, which is this turquoise-blue stone, so beautiful.
The area where she had her hair, her hands, a little over here, had all the lapis lazuli, of course, they assumed it was the princess.
There is the museum there, which is where I suppose there is all the artifacts.
I am not a super fan of archaeology, it would not be my passion, but well, let's see what there is.
The museum does not have much, the typical bowls, the typical stones, but yes, of course, the interesting thing is this.
Look, here it is as if they imagined the princess of Sarazam, they imagined it like this, and here it is, I understand, just as they found her,
buried there.
The lapis lazuli is this turquoise thing that has a hole in the middle.
I imagined the stones to be bigger, but wow, it's a lot.
A lot that, not 3,000 years ago, but 3,000 or 4,000 years before Christ, there were already this kind of things,
if they had found them in such a good state of conservation.
It also has a kind of bracelet here.
Well, it's a shame, but it's a good thing.
Well, it's a shame because it's a bit apprehensive about the scales, but it's a lot.
It also seems to me that there is like gold, I don't know if it's gold or some other type of metal.
Very well, very well, let's see if I can go to the abo and continue.
I went to the abo, well, with a cup, and apart from doing what I had to do, I took off my long pants.
Look, here it would not be the most humid environment in the world, but it is more humid than Uzbekistan,
which was all desert and it was different.
I think that when it's very dry, these pants can be useful, right?
But with the humidity they get stuck and it's getting quite hot.
It's only ten o'clock.
It's less hot at temperature than Samarkand, but I'm having more heat.
Well, well, short pants.
And when I'm in Palma Mir, maybe I'll put on the long pants again.
Yes, we'll see, we'll see.
It's still about eight kilometers or so to Panja Kent, which is the town I told you about.
Here is another town, and well, there were some cashiers.
I say, I'm going to withdraw money.
I think the town's light has gone out, because the supermarket doesn't have the light on either,
the toilets don't have light, and the cashiers don't work.
So I guess it's the electric issue that doesn't work.
A cold shower would have been fine.
Let's go, let's go.
This one has the light on and it's getting cold.
This is the
road that we drive along.
It's still hot.
As we go, there is a slight shade of trees.
Hello!
Everyone is very nice, hello!
Hey, hello!
First impacts on the country.
Everybody is very nice, everybody greets.
Now a few children who were on the other side of the road have come, they have come
in, they all helped me.
A lot of children are getting tired in the summer, well, today is Saturday.
Several people have already stopped to offer me what they eat in the evening.
I'll give them what I eat.
Bye, bye!
Bye!
I told them no, and one of them said, we don't charge you, no money, no money, and I said no, no, challenge, of course it's hard to explain, I still don't know the word for walking, I think it's pishko, but pishko is Russian, well, what else, a lot of people make use of a kind of motorcycle that carries a trailer behind, a lot of people, even children,
hello, hello, yes, what else, he doesn't move any air because we're in a boat and
that causes anxiety, you don't know, it's crazy to see what happens a bit in theера, because
and
this heat. There are still some, I don't know what else. Four kilometers to the village, come on.
It took a while, but I withdrew money. The city bank of Uxambe didn't work for me, but this one
here, well, I don't know, there's a turn. This one did work for me. Wow, good luck with the
bills. Yes, yes, a lot and everything. And I only took 200 euros, huh? And I already have
almost all my wallet. I think it will be a matter of leaving a few bills in the backpack
because otherwise I can't open the wallet and such. It didn't tell me anything about commissions.
That doesn't mean I haven't been charged yet. I'll find out when I open the bank's app that
I can't open it now because I don't have internet yet, which is the next step. Go to
search for the third one.
Megafon is the company I want because it has the best coverage in rural areas. But it turns
out that the system doesn't work. The system is broken, this bottle at least, and I have
to go to another one. There are others, but I've seen that one has a review of what a
team is.
Oh, my God. What was I going to say? Megafon, we did it, okay. Now that I've obtained
internet, I've been able to look at reviews and it turns out that the one that was a team
was the other. So I was lucky and went to this one, which wasn't a team. And it works
60 GB plus the welcome GB for 14 euros. Of course, Uzbekistan cost me 5 euros, but
well, it's fine. This girl says she's from Madrid, she doesn't like Barça, but she
told me to come and take a picture of her. This is typical, huh? Typical from Uzbekistan,
from Tajikistan.
Yes, it's Samsa, national Samsa.
National Samsa. Okay, thank you very much.
This is our national fruits.
National fruits, huh? I will take also a picture.
Yes. You can do some pictures. And you can do some pictures with this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay. Salamat.
She's speaking English.
Okay.
Salamat.
Okay, can you not do it at the
same time?
Okay, so...
I asked how it works.
I know that this is very small.
So this looks very good, but I want an air-conditioned place to sit down, charge
the battery and eat something.
At the moment everything is fine, I got everything at the first one.
The entrance to the city, as you said before, had some very large, very beautiful hotels,
everything.
Here is the market.
This is the big market.
The battery is charging here and I want to order some meat and I say to the guy, what is this?
Beer? Chai? But the guy has guided me to the plof.
Don't you want plof? I'm sure you don't want plof, and he says, well, come on, bring me a plof.
I say, an appetizer. Well, he has brought me an appetizer. But it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, what a place you are in, Evo.
This would never have happened. I stop at a ice cream shop and I say, an ice cream, please.
And when I go to pay, he says, no, no, free.
They had invited me to things, but they had never invited me to a shop to eat for free, you.
Well, you, you're a genius, you. Incredible.
Oh, and for lunch, it cost me four and a half euros. Very good.
At five in the afternoon, now it is not difficult to walk in the sun, but for everyone who stops and gives me a hand.
Great, huh? Well, the temperature has dropped a little because there are clouds.
This is good because it was a very difficult day, huh?
At six in the afternoon, moving a little slowly, I make a little stop,
because I'm tired. Here there are two interesting things that I want to show you.
One, Seven Lakes, 34 kilometers. This is one of the most famous areas in this part of Tajikistan.
From here to Dushanbe there is a mountain chain, I don't know what it's called, but it has seven lakes, seven yaks.
And it is a very famous excursion that is done by van, I think, from, well, they do it from here,
but also from this, from Uzbekistan. It is said that they are precious yaks.
I can't visit the seven yaks, because I go on foot and the seven is a pass.
But my intention is to visit at least two or three.
That's why I'm going to get out of the way, not here, but further on.
But well, when the topic arrives in two days or one, if so, I'll explain it to you later.
And I also like this back here, which is a monument that puts, well, the flag of Tajikistan,
the flag of China, I love it because it is my goal, China.
By the way, let's see, I've learned how to say walk in Tajik, which is piyodi, piyodi,
although everyone understands it in Russian too, but well, I'll say it in Tajik, piyodi.
And China as it was, piyoda, not piyodi, piyoda.
And China is hitoi, Tajikistan hitoi.
So, when they ask me something, I'll say piyoda hitoi.
Let's continue.
It's 7 o'clock.
Oh, look, a donkey.
I've made my last water supply.
I always say, well, two days ago I said I wanted to camp a little earlier because I'm tired,
but as you can see, I'm in a kind of village and I can't camp.
So, I have to keep going until I find something.
It shouldn't be difficult today, we'll see.
It's 7.20.
This man invited me to stay.
La cambdadora claiva.
Sí, sí, tal cual.
Después os explico
That is amazing.
What do we have to say now? Tajikistan va peix. Thank you.
A veure, a veure, l'home aquest agafa i em porta en cotxe a un lloc molt maco, com heu vist, brutal, a l'exposta de sol, aquests llacs,
aquests, les muntanyes, molt bucòlic. Diu que la seva casa està per allà, però després en diu, és que ell parlava d'anglès, però no ens hem acabat d'entendre.
Primer m'ha dit com que em convidava a casa, però després resulta que demà es casa la seva neboda i llavors té la casa plena.
Potser he trucat a algú i han dit, no, tenim la casa plena. No ho sé, és igual. Potser a una escura, no ho sé.
En qualsevol cas, m'ha fet la volta, m'ha quedat a casa.
I després m'ha dit, mira, et portaré a un restaurant, no sé si m'ha dit el restaurant del seu pare, no ho tinc clar,
però bueno, a un restaurant i podràs dormir aquí al restaurant. No és una habitació, però estaràs bé, jo.
Primer m'ha semblat que deia quinze minuts de cotxe, jo. Ja veuràs, demà hauré de fer autostop. No.
Està literalment a dos quilòmetres d'on m'ha recollit. Per tant, demà caminaré dos quilòmetres i continuaré des del punt de final d'avui.
I bueno, el lloc és molt maco.
El lloc aquest és.
És una casa on hi ha la cuina i és allà on he sopat.
Que per cert, he intentat pagar, encara que era evident que m'estaven convidant i m'han dit que no, que no, que no puc pagar.
Ok, jo sempre ho intento.
I donc a fora hi ha com una espècie de llocs com aquests, que són com tancats i privats, amb una taula i unes catifes i una cosa així còmoda per asseure-se.
I ja diferent, cada un, cada lloc aquest té un grup, no?
I el grup, doncs, doncs peta la xerrada.
No sé si s'escolta, perquè tinc la cancel·lació de sordida activada.
Vaig a desactivar-la un moment.
Bueno, tinc tant aquí com allà dos grups d'homes xerrant.
Clar, ara són les vuit i pico. Demà és diumenge.
Per tant, avui és el dia de dinar, de sopar fora i de fer xà-xara.
Clar, espero que no acaben muy tarde, porque si no...
¿Yo qué? ¿Yo cuándo duermo?
Y tengo bastante son, hoy.
A ver, espero que vaya bien la noche.
En todo caso, ya lo explicaré mañana.
El lugar es chulo, mola.
Pero claro, yo para dormir, no sé.
Además, hoy tenía ganas de hacerme una ducha.
Una ducha de estas que me tiran agua por encima.
Y claro, aquí, con la gente al lado, no.
Pero bueno, tengo un lavabo, tal.
No puedo quejarme, ¿no?, supongo.
Tengo la electricidad, ya...
La electricidad, ya de todo.
Ya, al costado aquí, si se me cayera algo por la noche,
ya hay agua.
O sea, estoy sobre de agua.
Que podrías decir, wow, aquí debe haber un saco de mosquitos.
No, no hay nada.
No acabo de entender muy bien por qué.
Hoy he visto muchas lobelulas.
¿Las lobelulas comienzan los mosquitos?
Bueno, no sé.
40 kilómetros, hoy.
39 y pico.
He hablado, no sé, hoy con muchas personas.
Yo qué sé.
10, 10, sí, sí.
Es que tanta gente me paraba.
Refrescos, 4.
Y grandes, grandes.
De diners, buf, avui és complicat perquè he pagat molt en efectiu, eh.
Crec que, contant l'entrada aquesta al museu,
potser...
11.
Bueno, la tarjeta 5, que m'ha costat 14.
En total, 25.
Bueno, primer dia a Tajikistán.
Creo que han aumentado la esencia del país.
La esencia son las montañas.
Pero bueno, un día bastante
intenso, eh, con la frontera,
esto que me acaba de pasar ahora, toda la gente diciendo hola,
la calor... Ha sido un día du, eh.
No ha sido un día agradable, de verdad.
En general, en global, no ha sido un día agradable.
Deixeu-me dir
una cosa del tema de las samarretes.
A ver,
por culpa de que nuestro proveedor
está de vacances, cosa que ya os voy a decir,
y de que habíamos hecho una comanda
de 60 samarretes y solo nos han
llegado 22,
eso por una banda. Y por la otra banda,
por culpa vuestra, porque nos estoy comprando
muchas, muchas, muchas gracias.
Pero, claro, nos estoy comprando
muchas y, claro, no tenemos
mucho stock. Entonces,
algunas de las que se han comprado hasta ahora
y las que se compran a partir de ahora,
probablemente no se enviarán
hasta septiembre.
Probablemente significa 100%, probablemente.
No se enviarán hasta septiembre.
Bueno, tú, la gente hace vacances y...
Nosotros hacemos lo que podemos.
Muchas gracias por comprarlas, pero bueno, que lo sepáis.
Vale, venga, ya está.
Buena nit.